we don't do who he'd love
he wouldn't exist I'm good I just have
to say I think there's a lot of women at
this point that are trying to audition
to me mrs. Jordan like no decision yeah
but this is the first time you're
playing a dad and I think like that is
it harder than the boxing or was that
like the easier part like what was it
having the kid on say I mean I know I
loved it you know I've um you know I
can't wait to be a father you know in
the right time you know comes for that
and to be able to imagine and make
believe that I had a daughter and you
know and have that family was uh was uh
it was really satisfying for me another
great aspect of the film I loved you and
Tessa like y'all's dynamic is just
absolutely amazing and it really shows
black love but I'd have to say your
chemistry with slides like my favorite
and I'm hoping that he maybe let some
Rocky 3 Rocky Ford Nuggets go this time
like you've been kind of tight-lipped
tell me something they told you from
bringing it like from back then that you
were surprised about or what's he like
that you me surprised about you mean
like him you mean like rocky or sly like
from the filming of the first couple
films like you bring anything back being
like this is just like what we did or is
there something about him maybe offset
that people be surprised about slides a
prankster the slide is very mischievous
so he definitely finds ways to to stir
stir the pot a little bit on set you
know he's always got a million stories
to tell because he's lived so much life
he's been through so much so to be able
to kind of like tell stories or you know
I don't know like changed labels on
things around said he's just he's a very
mischievous devious guy so it's always
fun with him also I would have been so
surprised about that one
I love the film I'll just go ahead and
say it was like so much fun by the
training montage so how did y'all
approach this one you
it's very different from the first
moment I think very different from all
the other ones how did y'all approach
making this one feel unique just trying
to see something that hasn't been done
before we haven't we haven't really seen
that desert montage before so me and
Steven you know and sly also trying to
find places to give some grit but also
makes sense in the story we wanted to
you know challenge physically what the
one of the biggest things about these
montages is what is he learning outside
of the Ring that he's gonna take with
him inside the Ring that's gonna
overcome the challenge and and we wanted
you know the pain obviously he needed to
be able to take the punishment that he
was obviously going to get and it's
about endurance there's like how how
much can you actually endure so you know
we took Adonis through hell you know we
took him to the breaking point I love
that yeah we felt it trust me
another one I think when I look back to
us going back to Fruitvale like Ryan's
not on this one but his DNA is all
throughout the film and I look at
y'all's partnership together you guys
have come to such great heights together
what do you think if you go back from
Fruitvale to now would be the biggest
battle that you fought with him no in
general in general and then what's been
the sweetest victory like going back
through these three films that kind of
like I think it brought you out at this
point another great question um I think
each movie is a battle so many things
has to happen right in order for a movie
to get made I think maybe
you say the greatest battle that we won
for I was gonna I'm gonna make it all
that way I'm not gonna put it all the
way I think it was it was it was a it
was tough to - sorry I graduate it was
tough to figure out black panther there
lot of people who realized I was in a
contract with you know with Fox for
Fantastic Four so technically I wasn't
supposed to be playing in Marvel's world
you know to play that character because
they still had an option on me so to be
able to kind of like make that work
between studios and got the Emma Watson
Jim gianopolous and Kevin Feige and
everybody that kind of got on the same
page and allowed that to happen but
there was a lot of mountains that needed
to be moved in order for me to play kill
monger and it was a collective battle
and we all kind of we kind of made it
happen they worked out so nothing really
matters to him right now
including me you got a real heart about
this do you have people that need you
know I'm taking the fight so you were
voted on our list of fearless female
heroines which we admire number four
with Valkyrie oh my god yeah can we just
talk about that kudos to you thank you
so much run down the list so you
actually know your number Street so it
was a working girl Tess McGill was
number two and then number one was Ellen
Ripley Wow yeah and then Valkyrie really
yeah so kudos to that but I think so
cool I think it's a theme with you to
like have these great strong also
vulnerable intensely feminine like
admirable women in your like cast of
characters that you've played they're
always that way I feel like that going
back to your white people and even going
back to Grace I mean last oh yeah so
what do you feel about Bianca how does
she show her string cuz I feel it's a
different type of strength that we don't
always see yeah you know it's
interesting that you said the word
strong and then you said all sorts of
other adjectives to me strong just means
that the character is finely drawn that
she isn't painted in broad strokes and I
really like sort of
trying to buck Convention and also I
think the truth is we are not confined
by the things that make us up in terms
of gender or race or any of those things
so I don't know IIIi love to play people
that are multifaceted because that's
kind of all I know how to do cuz that's
what we are you know and to be able to
bring my own humanity to two parts but
that's thank you so much for
acknowledging that around Tomatoes know
very definitely and then also on this
one we have to acknowledge your
songwriting skills made another
appearance yeah people don't know you
did perform the first one but also wrote
in the first one and then back at it
again talk about adding these
collaborators and how you know we just
added more I think to the tapestry of
yonkers hammer yeah well you know we
obviously these characters have evolved
in the in the space of whatever three
years since the sense he last saw them
on screen and so it was important for
Bianca's music to also evolve that a you
know a reflection of her maturity
happens inside of what's happening with
the music sonically and we also wanted
to play with this idea that maybe she's
you know invited a pop sensibility that
she is this artist that is transitioning
from being this indie artist that just
makes music in her living room alone to
being an artist that wants to reach you
know more people and how you do that and
so we had folks like James Fauntleroy
come in which was incredible and right
and Beebe Borelli came in and we wrote a
song together she's an incredible
independent artist but also writes for
the likes of Rihanna and that was so
cool I mean to get to work in the
company of the these people really are
just geniuses there's there's so Savanti
and I just it was so nice to be in their
presence and to also have them you know
sort of help Bianca's voice grow and
expand and it's so great I love the last
song and that's all I'll say about that
no spoilers but also the greatest I
think part of this movie is how great it
shows black love like yeah that scene in
the first one where Adonis is doing your
hair like I'm just like
relationshipgoals and it's not sexual
yeah talk about in this movie what's
that
non-sexual like inflammation of there
like relationship that you really likes
Oh like I love this scene when they're
in bed together sort of cuddling and
he's on her stomach and to me the thing
that's so beautiful about their love is
they can speak so candidly to each other
and they keep each other honest but
inside of a very romantic love which
they have is also just a platonic love
that comes from real true companionship
and I feel like that's something that is
like enduring and and really awesome and
like not the steamiest so you don't
always see it projected in Hollywood and
especially when we talk about
representation I don't feel like we see
that often enough with black folks on
film or we see it in a way that feels
specific to us and we have a movie that
feels for us by us like love Jones but
it's a you know it gets boxed into a
space of being insular or being like a
black movie and the truth is it's just a
good movie about humans who happen to be
black and I love that I love that sort
of like normalizing of our love that our
love is universal it looks like everyone
else's love but inside it there's also
specificity that has to do with undoing
braids and cocoa butter and silk wraps
on hair and all of that that we know and
understand so that when we go to this
end and when we look at the images
projected and we go oh I know that like
I've seen that like that sort of
recognition I think is deeply powerful
and particularly if you're not
accustomed to having it nearly enough
and also in the context of big movies
like this so it's not lost on me how
significant it is Victor Drago son of
Ivan Drago who infamously kill Apollo
Creed appeared today to issue a
challenge to Adonis Creed
don't do this I got a choice that's the
same thing your father said you died
right here in my hand first of all let
me just say the film was so much fun it
was great and I think the best part
that's gonna surprise people is y'all's
dynamic like the father-son like I I was
believing every minute of it so tell me
was there any behind-the-scenes stuff
that y'all used to kind of get that
father-son dynamic to feel so real
on-screen change yeah I mean you know we
really tried to create a father-son
relationship in an also excite of the of
the Ring and you know Dolph initiated it
a lot like he was asking me how to to
work out together to having dinner
together to do rehearsals together
because he really wanted to be authentic
while doing this father-son thing I
think we create a pretty strong bond and
we like each other in real life too
I think you can tell that on-screen and
yeah being authentic I think so yeah we
have to do our are incredibly exhausted
Russian lessons together and I kind of
you didn't want to do it I pushed you
into it many times exact it was gonna
pay off one day yeah yeah yeah you
didn't get to speak as much rushed into
the first witness what you guys are
going at it like a whole time which was
harder the Russian or the boxing Russian
definitely I'm in boxing you know it's
like it's also it was exhausting make no
mistake about that but the Russian stuff
being because we wanted you know
Dollfuss same as me if we do something
we want to do it as perfect as possible
and this language is a real tongue
breaker like to get the right
pronunciation on every single word it
was tough and rehearsing with our
dialect coach so many times like he said
you kept pushing me because I was like
Eddie and she was so scared of me
towards the end because she'd have to
tell the director that it wasn't correct
in my long speech and that's it what who
said that
and come on it's like it's 2:00 in the
morning should go but it shows on screen
because I don't know Russia but I
sounded it sounded great to me as I was
telling you Florian I've obsessed with
your Instagram because it's just it's
insane like you don't you look not human
it's not fair I really think but was
there a rivalry with Mike from that cuz
I have a feeling you guys you got to
before you know Mike became a very close
brother a very close friend of mine same
for Steven cuz you know we kind of the
new generation here like it's 31 Steven
30 I'm 28 and you know what I
appreciated about Mike a lot was that he
was very supportive so he he tried to
help me wherever he could it was the
same as stuff so like in total working
with this cast together was so easy no
egos walking around on set everyone
tried to support each other and I was
like family that's I think you can tell
that on screen that's why the movie is
getting so good along this family you
can't tell it on screen like I said
especially with you guys and Dolph I
know you've been acting for a long time
and I forgive me for saying it but I
think we're in the middle of a dolphin
asan's I mean with the cream and wish to
vote yeah you could totally can't with
arrow and with Aquaman coming out soon I
mean what do you feel it's like taking
this new sort of like resurgence in your
career and and and doing it still going
back to a character you played like 20
years ago sorry but 33 years ago well
it's a great feeling and I worked hard
for it but I think just time had to be
right I couldn't have done it 10 years
ago I don't think it was ready and I
don't think you have to you have to
reach a certain age for I think to that
to be able to play a father and play
more mature characters
and uh you know it feels great and this
film certainly because it's drawn
because it's a rocky thing it will be a
big part of that research and so Dolph
surgeons whatever you call it
Dolph initially after Brown you learn
more about yourself when I stepped in
every it wasn't all about me like
testing you know Ian complements on here
yeah the hair wrap thing you did talk
about the scarf and cocoa butter so like
the cocoa butter but back to the movie
man I have to talk about you know I
guess the the person who wasn't here but
he was a shadow over the whole thing and
that's be Ryan C both went to USC both
you know one a BFF shorts tell me about
how he approached you and he's booster
on this so just talk about y'all's
relationship I'm in car the project no I
haven't told a story yet but ironically
enough we were talking like a week
before I got the call from him GM was
not about Creed
it wasn't my ain't I camera what I was
asking about some personal dealing with
the career and he gave me some advice on
something so I had nothing to do with
the movie whatsoever and then a week
later studio call and they're like you
know hey we want you to direct create
two and I was like what y'all haven't
even met me yet and then they saw the
first features of lamb and then it was
like Luke spoke highly of you and slice
all the land actually to and responded
to it and so I was like man as I all
right let me meet with these guys and he
was super supportive obviously he went
to school together we have similar
tastes and a lot of things we're all the
same age meet him mic test everybody so
we just you know kind of just click that
I'm allowed to say that we just were
like oh let's make it happen
um so easy to say yes in that regard the
challenge obviously was like it's a seed
point you guys killed the first one like
how do we make it better and do you guys
want to make it better all right here to
make it better
um anyway
you know just wasn't like a money grab
or anything you guys like how do we grow
as characters and that's what we after
depth yeah I think it really shows them
the scene I think it shows in the most
and I forgive me Ryan I love two
sequences but the training concise yeah
that is just something out of this world
cause every Rocky movie has a training
montage it's like a huge part of the DNA
so talk about putting your stamp on that
and how like it went from concept to the
screen no for sure at first lie so I was
very adamant about doing something
different which is awesome
but he he he was like dude would it be
cool because I was in a snow they'd be
in a heat and I was like cool so he had
the idea of putting in a desert there's
supposed to be Death Valley in
California and then everything else as
far as the workouts I just started
looking up multiple workouts and then I
knew slice format and um you know the
montages they did the same thing in
Creed where you start off and go hide
and then boom just score kicks in and
you go crazy and so I knew the format
but I was really looking into like new
workouts people haven't seen and their
workouts that made sense in a fight
later how to endure pain hitting in a
place where he got hit earlier no ribs
and all that jazz and then the vomiting
felt real because I remember I saw
Florian working out one time and he
started throwing up and I was like dang
he's working out that he's just a
monster if you ever say you know yes so
that wasn't even anything else I'm
taking at him losing that and descript
we're gonna go vomit to all those
moments and in the car you know
obviously him sprinting the car being
symbolic for Apollo Creed being you know
president because his dad gave him that
card
it's a carryover from Creed one so it
meant something and so just trying to
give you bits of what you like from what
Ryan did in Korea one but yet then try
to put my own little thing to it yeah
also another thing that they did that
the movie does it great but the score
like Ludwick I think like just totally
just put just put so much on it so talk
about how working scoring that cuz again
another huge part about Rocky is the
music so how did y'all approach make it
feel different but the same I'll talk
specifically in that moment just because
that took a lot of work you know so Lou
like his processes as you like just keep
doing stuff at me you know and he's like
you know let's find something that works
and then Mike will was also in the mix
so like this is the first time the kind
of collaboration had happened
so between my quill I and him we were
all trying to find artists and in
Interscope got me hip to Jacob banks and
I was like dude I was starting off the
montage with a Nina Simone at first
oh wow and it was a strange fruit I mean
it Studios like yeah I get it
Ella is just for a tone vibe until we
get the vibe and I'm talking to Jacob
banks and Jacob banks like you want this
kind of deep broody and I was like at
the top of it I want people to feel the
grit like a Nina Simone type vibe like
it's the closest I could get my voice
and he kind of led the way so we used
his vocals as a template and then Mike
will just infiltrate beats and then
Louie does a whole entire score and then
a SAP came in oh my god just like to
have a like like a rock like jam session
oh yeah oh by the way the best part
about Ezra Krane is childish was in the
studio with us during the session the
kids you know it was his birthday a
shout-out to Childish I was my first
time meeting him so as we're actually do
this whole thing he came by with his
family his hip is all about
tonight pus-head it was right without
my lips
the tribulation
this won't be the end to me
are you
they can't be because we're a team
and you know what you fight before
[Music]
you
[Music]